hello everyone it's nice to be here in
the philippines my name is Cheech one
and today my topic will be web movements
in China so it's more like a more
general topic here and first let's just
make less let me make yourself
introduction by myself and I'm a founder
of adding planning platform in China and
is the startup company i co-founded
least a couple of friends and I'm also a
partner of a game development company in
Beijing and I I basically do coding at
my spare time so I'm collector I'm
creator of a Jes patents collection I
first I do it as a rep as a self
reference but somehow after i publish to
github it has been used by a lot of
people and it becomes a quite popular a
connection right now on github and if
you find it interesting you can check it
out on github it basically collects all
the JavaScript patterns like jQuery
patterns and a lot object creation
patterns as well and and in the past i
initialize the delta boilerplate a
project for the smartphones and it was
originally developed with a parish and
divya and now because I have my own
startup running and I didn't have much
time but it's carried on by alex gibson
and many other developers who continue
to work on this project and i'm also a
book author of html5 mobile development
cookbook and also reviewed book for the
same publisher in the past and since
this is jas kong asia i just want to
talk about something in asia so only
talk about something about the web
development in china and here is like
the browser's text in China right now it
looks a bit depressing because it seems
like I ate and I e-cigs are still kind
of like the most popular browsers a
chrome is catching
up in the country but even though html5
html5 started well supported in the
region yet but somehow the big web
companies and startups are trying really
hard to to to work on cross platform
solutions as well as using html5 in a
lot of web applications and first of all
talk about like html5 in like big tech
companies in in China it's like Alibaba
is the one of the biggest e-commerce
website is basically a combination of
amazon.com and paypal in China so it's
really huge and recently is converted
all is html5 text to HT HT HTML tags to
html5 cymatics tension is another huge
company and it starts as a chat
application a desktop software but after
it gained popularity in the country it
has developed into a web platform and
it's almost like a web version of the
operating system I just want to do like
a couple demos of how how it works so it
basically has like photo editors and
music players and it says like a clock
and of course it's chat system on this
Web OS as well and basically it
developed like RSS readers and like
music box and video players as well or
in 10 e 1 Y browser I'm sorry
and recently it uses all the latest like
html5 technologies for instance it used
the notification API for its chat system
and it also uses the the geolocation API
for its map and the Audio API for is
music player and for this core chat
application online it uses a WebSocket
by default for browsers that support
html5 and it uses flash enabled flesh
sockets for browsers that doesn't
support html5 browsers and it uses like
long polling for like no flash browsers
and of course it is asleep is uses like
css3 video API canvas API in WebGL 48
games and other applications but that is
quite common as we all seen those things
in the in other parts of the world as
well but what is more exciting is about
how startups come up with more creative
solutions for problem solving and one
problem we know that when we are doing a
smartphone application is that if you're
running it in the browser itself on a
smartphone the performance can be a
problem especially in like Asian
countries like people are kind of like
more pragmatic you know like they care
about the development course edited the
development costs and as well as how can
you find such good developers who can
make it like work smoothly and no
flickering problems and so this startup
called app can come up with a quite
interesting solution it's basically a
hybrid smartphone solution and it works
for iOS Android and Windows 8 and it is
bit similar to a phonegap but is but it
also has some kind of difference so with
these kind of solutions like this has
become like cliche like
web versus native because this app can
has basically a App Engine so basically
you're right you're called in html5 and
css3 and can compile it into a app using
the app engine and it comes with the
developer SDK as well and as well as app
analytics and it has also its own push
notification but we all know that
phonegap can pretty much do the same
thing so what is like the difference
like if you're using phonegap most
probably you are building a what all in
one page application so basically is in
HTML that you you can hold it into a
webview and it works with jquery and
sencha touch and other third-party
frameworks and it's open source well
this all in one page plus third-party UI
framework approach has an pros and cons
the good thing is that this approach
works fine in demos and small
applications and but if you're building
a large application and which may
require multi views and no flickering
transitions then this become a little
bit of a problem and as we all know this
is how like a typical Android multi
webview development work place looks
like that you have all these layout
files which is like the web views and
you have the Java activities that
correspond to your layout
phonegap does have a solution although
is not commonly used by people for
Android web views phonegap uses a diva
webview and for iOS web use it uses
cleaver component but these are not
really commonly used and it's not like
but they work as more like components
instead of the core application and how
ab can does this is that by default it
has a multiple web view API and it has
the native app can you I which is a
building UI framework it's not open
source at the moment but it's kind of
afraid to use basically this is how the
multiple value API looks like so with
this development SDK you instead of
having one index 2.html you actually
have like multiple htmls which work as
different web views and corresponding
there there is this JavaScript which
works there's activity and us the you
the the UI framework built in as well
and because of there's something running
in the background so it solves the
flickering problem as well when you
actually translating from one webview to
another and this is how the UI framework
API looks like basically this is how the
native API you I API works on a very
basic layer there's a red resolution
adapter class and on top of that you can
find the base class the color class the
layout and resolution class and also on
top of that you have the control class
which controls the buttons least fold
inputs tab radio box check box and
switch classes and you can write your
own custom class as well so which is
better I think I love
phonegap before it's open-source nature
and the only one page solution is really
easy for like entry-level developers and
the flexibility is really great for
top-level developers app can is is more
like it's a bit like a free enterprise
product is good for mid-level developers
I think so it's really your own choice
like what use but I think it's quite
interesting to to learn a tool to have a
look at both because they use different
approaches and and I think they can
learn a lot from each other and there
are a lot of quite interesting apps
viewed by just made in JavaScript itself
in China like one of these is called
like daily cost and it's building
JavaScript and it's written by just one
single person from the design to
development and to the marketing self
and it's like half a million downloads
in the country and well if you say like
I don't even give know about ie 6 and 8
users is still fine because like in
China and many Asian countries like even
a niche market is still like bigger than
most conscious entire population like
Indonesia China Japan so even if you
just build like an application that's
totally just it does only supposed html5
but not other browsers still can be a
quite heat like for instance one music
player built by a by a developer in
China called qingdao FM which is quite
interesting it's like a music player
built entirely in html5 it has quite a
lot of users and also there's like a
platform as a service for responsive web
one of the company's called all
mobilized in China I think there are
some quite of similar companies in the
US and in verse as well and basically
currently there are like hundreds of
millions of web pages has been converted
to responsive web pages by using this
tool and
many other stock web platforms and there
is this chat application called we chat
in China which is quite similar to
whatsapp in the US or lying in Japan but
if but the difference is that it also
has grown into an app store which
supposed html5 game development so there
are a lot of html5 game development
companies in China that uses this Web
Store to publish apps and some of them
are quite a experimental at this stage
but slowly they're gaining like
popularity so the conclusion is that
despite the fact that I eight and six
are probably still the most popular
browsers in China but there's increased
support of html5 for for the the
customers and the big tech companies are
really adapting really adopting html5
technologies and startups are also
started challenge the status core and
building really interesting applications
using age 15 technology and here are
just some like references I talked about
like the open source frameworks I built
in the past and as well as the company I
talked about in China that used entire
web OS on the browser itself and also
the one Chinese startup that boost the
app can which works a little bit like
PhoneGap but use a different approach
and basically that's my presentation
thank you everyone
mr. all right thank you so much she but
sure so we have time for a question or
two does anyone have any questions hey
our speaker Simon here has a question I
thanks great talk I've got two questions
actually all right one is you have a
really big base of windows XP in China
right and you finding the users on those
machines are installing chrome or are
they just staying with whatever whatever
they got second question is that can
localize into English Rose are only
available in Chinese I'm sorry you'll be
like if I want to use f kin uh-huh is
the interface in Chinese or English or
the documentation oh yeah the
documentation is the product problem
yeah it's due in Chinese but you can ask
me probably okay yeah and and also the
chalice trip everybody can understand
JavaScript so yeah that is you it's
gonna be yeah you have you can always
view the source code yeah and this a
little bit of casting you can know how
it works yeah I that is the kind of like
a problem in China it's like most
developers don't share that much with
the rest of the world although they are
building some quite awesome applications
and frameworks yeah and that's yeah I
probably can try to talk to them if they
can yeah have an English translation or
something yeah we're not providing
chinese translation yeah so what about
the the windows XP nice and chrome
people installing modern browsers into
their computers or are they staying with
their they're all browsers so you have a
lot of Windows XP users in China right
sorry me windows XP yeah a lot of
Windows XP in China people installing
modern browsers internet so then install
and crime on to XP right i mean with is
it's very complicated in china so there
are a lot of local browsers as well like
like like built by the chinese companies
tech companies but they actually use the
the chrome engine most of them yeah so
it's like it's very complicated and
there are still a lot of IE in china and
it's not going
to disappear in the very short period of
time during away 15 years yeah yeah it's
not going off and but the interesting
thing is like in China there are a lot
of smartphone customers so so people
spending more time to us spending most
of time to browse on a smartphone or a
tablet instead of on their desktop so
this created a huge opportunity for web
developers to try to come up with
solutions to work around with smartphone
devices so which is like a lot of
developers used currently develop html5
applications on the smartphone and like
AB cane is one example and a lot of
users a lot of developers uses phonegap
as well and and also just and and also a
lot of apps are just running in the
browser itself like use responsive web
approaches yeah great thanks a lot yeah
thank you all right well that's all the
time we have for questions today for
sure if you do have any more questions
hop on over to the chat and you could
also approach to over at the coffee
break later on